let's jump to the story from the New
York Post doxing truck drives around
Harvard showing names photos of students
who blamed Israel for Hamas attacks
that's the that's the story giant video
screens hung on the sides of trucks
posting the names of these individuals
so the story is a bunch of student
groups signed a letter that explicitly
said the only the only one to blame for
this is Israel and it's led to a major
backlash a truck is now posting their
names and you've got more CEOs signing
on saying they will never hire any one
of these students
who signed one of these letters and I'm
sitting back putting my feet like don't
don't look at me for help hello cuz
that's the same thing y'all did for
every other issue every other time so hi
that's Karma it's like y'all you you we
we begged you not to do this we said
cancel culture is wrong people should
should have their free speech there's
there are certain limits I don't think
everything's absolute right some people
don't want to associate I get it but the
line the left Drew was so ridiculous
like comedy Bann you know a 10 year you
made a comment 10 years ago banned uh-uh
we we misinterpreted what you said
you're fired okay y you made the rules
buddies yeah you wanted to sign on to
this they thought they were on the right
side of history but they weren't and now
they will never get jobs again talk
about wasting your your your uh college
Years o must be brutal for
them and especially considering like you
said I think it was you brought the
point it's like most of them actually I
think it was Tim sorry that they're just
jumping on because their peers are so
you're not even thinking about it and
you mess yourself up there's a tweet
think I can't remember the guy who said
it I could probably pull it up but he
said you know I'm not going to I'm not
going to cut anybody some slack over
signing this but you know got to
understand a lot of students didn't even
know what the letter was when they
signed on to it and I'm like wow that's
even worse yeah it is yeah then you kind
of deserve it even more then it has
nothing to do with what they signed it's
the fact that they signed it at all that
they would they would be kept out of it
I do have an issue with the idea of
compelled speech though like there was a
bright article today or yesterday it was
like these top the top 10 Instagram
celebrity the top 10 Instagram
celebrities with the most followers who
haven't said anything about Israel I
like I thought I like I thought 10 years
ago we or five years ago we said these
people are idiots who don't know
anything about foreign policy and we
didn't care what their opinions were I
don't like that either I don't like the
idea of either side telling me or anyone
that I have to have an opinion on
something so this is a professor at
Harvard who tweeted I yield to no one in
my revulsion at the statement apparently
made on behalf of 30 plus Harvard
student groups but please everybody take
a deep breath many these groups never
saw the statement before it went out in
some case those approving did not
understand exactly what they were
approving probably some were naive and
foolish this is not a time where where
it is constructive to vilify individuals
and I am sorry it's happening oh a
Harvard Professor he probably agrees
with them but let me just say uh my
friend you know there were there were a
lot of Nazis I love we'll just go
straight Godwin's law on these people
because it's related to Israel there
were a lot of lowlevel Nazi soldiers who
did not know what was going on but they
loaded those people up on TRS and trucks
all the same and we held accountable
held accountable for it just doing your
job is not an excuse these people at
Harvard signed onto a statement
empowering it and it was shockingly
offensive to a lot of people now I don't
know that my personal values like I
would fire someone who said something
shocking and offensive to an extreme
degree I'd probably just talk to him
about it and be like I don't know man
like consider the implications of what
you're saying and whether it's
strategically you know valuable and then
I I do have my lines though I think
everybody does if I put it this way if
you were hanging out with your buddies
at a bar and one guy got up and started
screaming racial slurs at somebody you'd
be like dude stop what are you doing
like knock it off that's not cool and so
that's basically what's happening right
now the issue I take with the farle was
that their cancel culture was always
extreme a guy there was a race car
driver whose dad said the nword in the
80s so his sponsors canceled on him like
that's nuts there there Sarah Silverman
did blackface 10 years ago so they get
her fired from a movie I'm like M well
you know she she she made her bed she's
going to lay it that's crazy if somebody
has an extreme opinion then I think it's
like you criticize them for it you
question them for it and depends on what
that that the the severity of the
opinion the problem was the left was
getting people fired and canceled for
the most tepid conservative opinions
nothing right and they still do I mean
we can't also pretend as if like that's
completely over it's definitely softened
but you know that still happens all the
time so fire with fire I guess fire with
fire it's them set of fire and burning
themselves and me sitting back and being
like me out of it yeah live by the die
by that's that whole that whole thing is
like you know you get what you give we
talk about lot like the the cult will
come for you if you yeah live by the
sword Die By The Sword it's an ancient
phrase um that like if you live your
life canceling people well you're going
to surround yourself with other people
that love to cancel people and then
watch out one day for you comes around
but that doesn't mean I won't forgive
them and welcome them back but I do not
trust people that snap to Crazy
judgments of others they don't even
consider themselves friends they
consider themselves allies they don't
have yeah they're comrades but that's
that slippery slope that they never seem
to understand either you know it's like
to them it's a fallacy to anyone who
pays attention to how life Works
Humanity Works history works that's not
a fallacy At All by the sword comes from
the Bible it does Matthew 26:52 yep was
that something Jesus then said Jesus
unto him put up against uh again thy
sword into his place for all they that
take the sword Shall Perish with the
sword yes what is he saying like so grab
your sword and get and arm yourself is
that what he's saying or he say put it
back no it's it's it's a proverb it's
basically saying live by the sword Die
By The Sword yep that's where it comes
from I feel bad if I was Sheamus I would
have known that when I was right Sheamus
is probably at home right now being like
you didn't know that you said an ancient
sorry Sheamus come back on the show I
need you but I guess also the part of it
is they don't really realize it's a
sword to begin with right like they
don't when they're when they're ruining
people's lives over the most minor
infraction which they are so accustomed
to doing they don't actually think about
that person's life after in any regard
so to them it's nothing so the slightest
bit of blowback to them it's like maybe
we'll rethink some things now actually I
think the worst of them do think about
it I think they want you homeless in a
box they want you they want you to
suffer uh and die alone on the streets
with no money that's why it's so
Insidious that it's not enough to just
have you scolded it's not enough to just
have you criticized you have to be given
you have to have everything taken from
you before in in there that blood is
never quenched right and they'll say
things like it's about accountability
culture it's like first of all who are
you to hold me accountable for anything
you're not God you're not my parents
you're not any you're no one but it's
like that's not accountability when your
entire life is dismantled because of a
tweet from 10 years ago and that's more
on the extreme example of what happens
but it's not as if that's super rare
that happens there's something higher
than both God and your parents they're
the offended and that's that's
apparently above all yeah yeah
accounting is like when you're taking
accurate cost benefit cost analysis and
if you're over accounting if you're
doing it wrong maybe you're charging too
much for the value like ruining
someone's entire livelihood because they
wore blackface 10 years ago I feel like
it's over overdoing it it's a misac
account for you to determine what the
accountability should be is like even
that even if I'm going to be held
accountable let me figure out how to
make amends with myself with what I've
done you don't tell me what to do well
if you have blackface you can still be
the prime minister of Canada so yes it's
okay or orar oh yeah Governor I forgot
about that true but we we never knew if
it was it was blackface or the clan
costume which one he never answered
that's the best part he's like's like
like to this day he's going to take that
to his grave it'll be in his Memoir when
he writes a book schinger is racism are
you talking about
G
not the governor yes yes who not noram
oh Governor Ralph Northam yeah and
that's just to distract you from the
whole 9month abortion thing yeah yeah
which is crazy it's wild
I I was just like getting uh like all
that I feel like we're talking about
racism cancel culture that stuff is like
it feels like vomit that's like kind of
out of me now but I keep it's like still
with me kind of but then I think about
like Israel Palestine and it's and then
I feel like I'm burning in hell so I'm
not sure this is crazy this is 2019 it's
nuts four years ago y blackface and KKK
Garb and we don't know which one he was
so he is in a super position of both
offensive costumes at the same time
so it's like I actually clone myself and
I'm both people at the same time well no
it's just like if he's not going to tell
us which one he did then he's
both that's crazy because you it's
because like both has like their own
like individual problems with it that
make it worse so he's like he doesn't
want you attaching whatever is worse
about either one of those in particular
ones to that exact costume you the crazy
thing is it was in their yearbook or
something yeah yeah yeah it was or I
think I think Trudeau was also I think
it was a yearbook thing but that's also
kind of the revisionist history that
goes on and people really pretend as if
like Nazi jokes were not acceptable even
like 10 years ago
there's dressed up like Hitler on Conan
or something like everyone kind of did
it that's the reason you can pull up all
these mainstream celebrities it's like
there's a reason why they weren't
canceled in the moment and then it aired
on live television it's because we kind
of did have a sense of humor who did you
say dressed up as a a Nazi on S
Silverman oh really interesting as
Hitler
pretty sure okay and it's okay because
she's Jewish that was what the whole
point was at least I'm really I'm
concerned comedy is okay like you had
count dankula's famous video where he he
had the Pug doing the salute and it was
it was it was like he said the cutest
thing in the world doing the most
repugnant thing possible that was the
the joke of it he was insulting Nazis
and then there's a story about like some
guy actually in in Germany trained his
dog to do it and then he got in trouble
CU they were like how dare you insult us
but they they tried they they tried to
lock him up yeah
well they did they actually but then he
but he got he got he went to core I
think I think he had to pay a fine or
something he did get he get arrested I'm
pretty sure yeah he he get arrested I'm
pretty sure he got tried for it and went
to prison he didn't go to prison I don't
think he went to prison believe I I
don't know thought he pay a fine or
something but then he made another video
where he had his he has he has a white
pug and a black pug and he made the
black pug do the black power fist which
is effectively the same thing that video
was so good and then like as as as it's
doing it there's a knock on the door and
he's like oh no it's the labor party and
then he has to like hide all of his
books and then like I got to hide books
and then he he's going through his
bookshelf he's like uh and then he grabs
the Tora on he's like oh crap oh crap
doesn't know what to do yeah it looks
like he was fined yeah he was 800 and I
mean that type of humor that was very
very there's actually a picture of like
Taylor Swift at like a Halloween costume
from like 2009 and the guy she's with
has a swastika on his shirt wow and like
she like but the thing is they'll just
Overlook it if you're if if you sell
enough pumpkin spice lattes and albums
like they'll just let it go yeah dude
but also there's something to be said
about the fact that it wasn't that
offensive back then people would see it
as funny even though obviously it's
egregious imagery and it reminds you of
obviously the atrocities but there was a
time when people didn't necessarily
internalize it as that person actually
being a Nazi it was really just a
Halloween costume yeah we'll get back to
the place where symbols aren't the same
thing as actions it sometimes they they
wave in and out of reality like you
forget what a symbol used to mean or it
means something new and then it no
longer means it like what's more what's
more vile having a swastic on your shirt
or kill
someone or or celebrating and defending
those who do like this is the point when
it people need to understand the the
actual moral qualms that exist with
cancel culture it's not so much that
someone said something shocking and
offensive so they got fired it's that
what they said actually wasn't shocking
and offensive and they got fired so when
like Sarah Silverman does a bit about
blackface she's trying to be a shock
comedian we get what she's doing she's
not literally intending to insult black
people but she got fired from a movie
over it that's ridiculous when Harvard
students sign a letter blaming Israel
for the mass murdering of civilians then
we kind of like I can look you should
not hire these people and I'll tell you
why it's not cancel culture anyone who
signed that letter showed that they are
stupid M did not read it did not think
ahead do you want to hire someone to
your company who blindly marches with
morons or do you want to hire someone
who's like I read that letter and said
no way it's one of two options you're
stupid or you're evil and neither one of
those are someone I would want in my
life any capacity definitely not someone
I'm giving money to or both or both most
likely both but you know but that's it
it's like SAR made s Sarah s makes a
joke and other people have made jokes
like okay keep your job I don't care and
then they explicitly defend terrorism
and it's like okay you know you're bad
people I don't want to be around you yep
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net